annexin 5 Pi assay is one method of  detecting apoptotic cells if the cell is  apoptotic then anexin 5 would bind to  the exposed phosphatidyl serine residues  generally phosphatidyl serine residues  are present in the inner leaflet but in  an apoptotic cell they are present on  the outer leaflet that simply means in  the healthy cell there would be no bound  annexin5 dye but in the apoptotic cells  annexin 5 dive would be bound to the  phosphatidyl serine  in technical terms first you have to  remove media from the cell wash it with  PBS add these annexin 5pi walking  solution incubate it in the dark and  then perform the flow cytometry  in the flow cytometry result we can see  whether the cell is viable early versus  let apoptotic or even necrotic watch the  full video